it's going to be intense from beginning
to end with not so much ramp up who else
is feverishly trying to devour every
crumb of information about the final
season of stranger things we'll be
getting into everything we know from the
release date The Plot and the fate of
some of our beloved characters number
one this seems pretty inevitable time is
a tricky thing especially when filming a
TV show that focuses on kids ideally
we'd have shot season four and five back
to back but there was no feasible way to
do that because of how quickly the cast
changes before our eyes we are most
likely going to experience a time Jump
because of how long the show takes to
film how that jump will play out in this
story we're unsure number two not only
is he still alive but he's a major
player in this final season and so is
someone else we thought we'd lose but
more on that in a minute at the end of
season 4 will tells Mike that vechna is
hurt but he's still around if that's not
enough to confirm he's going to cause
more trouble for everyone Jamie Campbell
Bower claims he knows all about season
five and to take from that what you will
number three regardless of everything
else the ending is solidified I don't
think we've deviated truly in any season
for the finale we've always stuck to it
also to get to that ending there's no
time for build up or normalcy season 5
starts completely action-packed and
drives forward at full speed it's just
gonna be going 100 miles an hour from
the beginning Matt and Ross wrote the
opening scene pretty early on and
according to them it starts out wild and
intense right from the jump number four
this one is pretty heart-wrenching
according to Matt and Ross Duffer Max is
in what in real life we would call an
irreversible coma she has no use of her
brain and is in pretty rough shape but
in the world of stranger things who
really knows when talking about her
irreversible coma in the happy sad
confused podcast we get this little
tidbit train didn't blind and all of her
bones broken yeah doing she's doing
great job even Sadie sink has no idea
what's in store for Max she says The
Duffer Brothers have been very secretive
about it number five the upside down
takes over this is going to be major and
definitely appropriate for a blowout
finale we've always wanted the upside
down encroaching into Hawkins in a more
massive way we hinted at it a little bit
in season two but we want a full-blown
upside down Invasion and that's
something you just can't hit the rewind
on number six do you think you'll get a
new haircut
unfortunately that's kept tightly Under
Wraps but what we can tell you is that
he's going to be the main focus of
season five going back to how season 5
is circling back to season one will
byers's disappearance was the main
storyline we are going to be finding out
exactly why that happened Will's going
to be a big part and focus we're
starting to see him coming of age really
which has been challenging for a number
of reasons some of which are
Supernatural but you're starting to see
him come into his own not only will we
be seeing his character Arc and coming
of age story but we're going to find out
about his connection to the upside down
how he and vakna are connected and why
he was chosen in the first place The
Duffer Brothers also plan on exploring
his love life saying it's going to be
much easier to talk about in the show's
final season number 7. a character so
short-lived but so impactful will that
really be the last we ever see of Eddie
we can't be totally sure what we do know
and we quote is that his demise is going
to have some huge repercussions for the
rest of the gang number eight there are
so many questions we're going to get
answers to in the final season one of
them being why the upside down is stuck
in the past that's something we don't
answer in volume 2 and that is really
the key plot point the key question that
is going to drive our final season as we
try to wrap up this story and give the
rest of the answers out number nine
Millie Bobby Brown really wants to see
some character demise here I do want her
to die she needs to die right but Matt
and Ross Duffer don't agree with that
type of storyline they said this is
stranger things not Game of Thrones what
did Millie call us she said we're
sensitive Sallys she's hilarious believe
us we've explored all options in the
writing room just as a complete
hypothetical if you end Mike that's
depressing we feel most confident that
we probably won't have to endure more
heartbreak in that area but that does
bring us to our next Point number 10
there's going to be a lot of them when
The Duffer Brothers brought season 5 to
the same Executives they pitched season
one to they got a powerful emotional
response that indicates we'll all be
crying for days everyone there had also
been present when we first pitched the
show in 2015 while we were strangers
then we were now friends and there were
a lot of Tears when it was over they
said they saw Executives crying who they
had never seen shed a single tear before
number 11. say goodbye to California and
Russia according to Matt and Ross Duffer
season 5 will be circling back to season
1 in a major way including going back to
Hawkins Indiana Joe Kiri who plays Steve
told Esquire Hawkins is the origin of
everything and also where everything
will end number 12. whatever it is we're
here for it we've been developing the
story which we haven't told anybody yet
so I don't even know if anyone's gonna
like it we think everyone including
Netflix will be surprised when they hear
the concept because it's very very
different apparently the only person who
correctly guessed what it could be about
was Finn wolfhard tell us your theories
in the comments number 13 the season 4
episodes had majorly long run times not
like we're complaining one thing we know
for sure about season 5 is that The
Duffer Brothers want the episodes to run
a lot shorter characters are already
going to be in action they're already
going to have a goal and a drive and I
think that's going to carve out at least
a couple hours and make this season feel
really different we also know that the
title for episode 1 is called the crawl
number 14 we're not too surprised about
this one we know we said the episodes
are going to be shorter but the finale
is going to be grand we can't expect
anything less considering the season 4
finale ran over two hours long The
Duffer Brothers told Josh Horowitz on
the happy sad confused podcast that the
last ever episode isn't sparing anything
I'm sure the wrap-up will be a lot
longer it's going to be Return of the
kingish with like eight endings number
15 we know that's top priority
information
unfortunately though it's not some of
the most concrete what we do know is
that it's most likely not going to be
until late 2023 or even more likely
sometime in 2024 the writing of season 5
is underway that was confirmed in August
of 2022 with this picture from the
writer's room according to Millie Bobby
Brown filming is supposed to start in
2023 but they also don't tell her much I
know as much as you know I really really
am clueless and also they don't want to
tell me I've got a huge mouth are you as
excited as we are for the next
installment of stranger things although
we're dreading the end we can't wait to
see how things will turn out with Will
Max vechna and the upside down do you
have any theories for the final season
share them with us in the comments